a wide
range of subjects of mutual interest and
we reaffirmed our commitment to
consistently strengthen the
comprehensive strategic partnership
between our countries that is
underpinned by long-standing traditions
of friendship solidarity and mutual
support
we welcome
the regular political contacts on the
high and the highest level that have
been continuing despite the coronavirus
pandemic and we paid special attention
to implementing the agreements
between our leaders including during the
telephone conversation between our
respective leaders on september 16 of
this year we share the view that the
free trade agreement between the
eurasian economic union and vietnam
had a real impact and helped increase
our trade it was up 15
last year
and added another 24
since january of 2021 we
also discussed possibility for expanding
trade by
expanding the footprint of
russian exporters in
vietnam
we discussed
setting up
the
assembly of russian vehicles in vietnam
industrial cooperation
infrastructure
construction
we also
discussed
cooperation
in
information security e-government smart
cities banking
anger industry communications
and we also
praised
cooperation in the oil and fuel sector
and we welcome further efforts to
develop this sector we affirmed our
commitment to stepping up a military
technical cooperation
and strengthening our respective
security we believe it important
the project to build the nuclear science
center in vietnam
and we also attach great importance
to the research facility on tropical
diseases that is also located in
vietnam
and
we are also attaching great importance
to granting scholarships to vietnamese
students during this academic year
year 1 000 vietnamese students were
awarded
russian government scholarships
and overall 6 000 vietnamese students
are studying in russia and by this
indicator vietnam is one of the top
countries represented in the russian
academic sector
we discussed
topical and urgent international matters
discussed our cooperation
in the united nations and within the
asia-pacific
region we
share
the view that we need to build an
architecture of equal and indivisible
security in the asia pacific region
based on universally recognized norms of
international law and we share the view
that any attempts
to
draw new dividing lines in the
asia-pacific region are
counterproductive
we will keep working effectively
together on implementing the agreements
reached by the leaders of our countries
thank you
i'd like to say hello and express my
gratitude i've been to russia several
times before but this is my first
official visit as foreign minister
i've
been very glad to have a meeting with
minister lavrov and a number of russian
officials
they gave me a very
warm welcome
vietnamese leaders
have visited russia on a number of
occasions
and president putin also came to vietnam
he
actually visited vietnam five times
the world and our country
has been going through a lot of changes
but
the friendship doesn't uh change
and neither does our gratitude
to
russia for
its uh support
in the past and currently
our relations with russia
has have always been full of trust
and
vietnamese people see
russia as a very close friend
we are starting a new stage in our
development so we
seek to become
a
developed country
and
to conduct independent foreign policy in
this regard
based on multilateral diplomacy
international integration
developing comprehensive strategic
partnership with russia and
this is one of our priorities in our
foreign policy we understand that only
loyal friends such as russia are going
to
accompany vietnam on its journey forever
we've had very fruitful talks with
minister lavrov
as minister lavrov already told you
about some results
i
would like to reiterate certain points
our relations have been developing in a
wide variety of areas we've strengthened
cooperation in terms of uh
security
and then
education
and so on despite the pandemic we've
been in regular contact at the official
level
and as
mr lavrov has already
mentioned recently
president putin had several calls with
vietnamese leadership
uh including with our uh president
our trade has increased 19 percent uh in
the last six months
we are very grateful uh to russia for
its timely help in terms of vaccine
supply
russia
supplied uh sputnik v
doses to vietnam and also supplied
materials so that we could manufacture
it in vietnam
of course
our close friendship and our
deep trust
is what lets us achieve such impressive
results
still we have a lot of opportunities and
we have good relations
so
that will help us to further develop our
comprehensive strategic partnership
we've discussed
measures and further steps to develop
our relations we've been preparing for
top level official visits
and
we've talked about
facilitating trade and creating
good conditions for it we've discussed
energy projects oil and gas projects
science and research projects
and so on
we've
agreed
that
vietnamese diaspora should have good
conditions in to live in russia
vietnam
highly values the
contribution that russia has made
to establishing uh peace in the world uh
in general and in the asian pacific
region in particular
our countries
have
supported each other
at the u.n
and
vietnam is positive about
russia's determination to develop its
ties with
asean and to develop closer ties with
the asia pacific in general
we believe
that any
disagreements
should be resolved in accordance with
international law and the maritime
treaty of 1982
will continue to develop our cooperation
and
we'll uh give an additional impetus to
our uh respective ministries so
that they could make good progress
on the existing projects
and i believe that our ties
will be uh developing constructively for
the benefit of our people thank you
i am a correspondent at the vietnamese
news agency
and my question is for minister bhutan
how would you assess the current state
of our bilateral relations
or what's what further cooperation is
there going to be in the
energy sphere
well
energy is a big area of cooperation for
us considering that we are strategic
partners
russia's uh
biggest companies uh such as gazproms
arabeshneft
and
so on continue to operate
successfully in vietnam and of course we
also have our joint company
via petro
we hope
that
in the future
we'll have even more joint companies
like that
we faced many challenges along the way
but
i can reassure you
that there is no threat to our energy
cooperation
nothing can undermine it
we'll do our best
to
continue
cooperating
the sphere of oil and gas and also
developing downstream projects
apart from
oil and gas we'd like to
develop cooperation in other areas
particularly
renewable sources of energy
this is not only in the interest of our
of both our countries it also helps with
peace stability in the region
good afternoon tas my question is for
minister bhutan
recently
some
countries experienced tensions
so
when it comes to moscow
and hanoi
what are the priorities now
thank you for your question
the pandemic has affected
our country in many ways of course
however
despite all the challenges
our relations
have been developing continuously
our leadership has a high level of
mutual trust
we've been in regular contact
over the
phone and we've seen good progress in
terms of trade and investment
we've seen growth
and turnover
and we share the values of
solidarity
we try to support each other while
facing these challenges and i would like
to say once again that we have very
close ties and that
we are grateful
for the
vaccine doses that russia supply to
vietnam and materials that russia supply
to vietnam
of course it was impossible to avoid
all the uh effects that the pandemic
has had
we had to adjust the official visit
schedule
and so on
because of the epidemic we have to put
off these things
of course we are
going to
pay particular
attention
uh to certain areas
and we will
facilitate uh closer
ties
whether it comes to politics economy
security
uh we are going to continue preparing
for top-level official
visits and we're going to make sure
that economic cooperation reflects
the
close ties that we have
we're going to develop more projects in
oil and gas in education and research
and development
we're also going to
work harder on the spheres that are of
mutual interest such as
agriculture farming and energy
we're also going to try to
use
our potential to the maximum
when it comes to interacting with russia
and the eu
and implement the
existing
project
[Music]
moscow
news agency
my question is from minister lavrov
so recently
uh we can say it's been a year after the
uh armenia azerbaijan flair of tensions
so
how would you assess this period what
achievements
would you say what pro what progress
would you say have has been made and uh
also
uh the us has been actively
uh promoting the issue of uh resolving
the status of nagorno-karabakh as soon
as possible
so
what are the objectives of the men's
group now then in the light of this and
are we
going to see any progress in terms of uh
structure and movement
for the year that we're marking since
november 9 2020 is that
there is stability it is being
maintained
and the russian
peacekeepers
are
helping uh ensure that there is
no violence there are minor incidents
that happened
in the beginning they were resolved
quickly
and
now the situation is stable although
there are many issues in terms of
how all the arrangements for the return
to peaceful lives are made demining
operations and the liberation of the
detainees these are all issues and you
were right to say that the main
objectives at this point is to bring
life back to normal on the ground so
that both the azerbaijani and the
armenian communities can build trust
as we saw before the first karabakh war
but there is also a need to resolve the
refugee issues and other
issues as for the co-chairs of the osce
men's group three co-chairs russia the
united states and france
had a meeting with the foreign ministers
of azerbaijan in armenia this happened
in new york and
as far as i understand they agreed
on
the visits to the regions and
the contacts on the ground with
representatives of armenia and
azerbaijan there was a meeting planned
in steppen accurate so we need to
encourage these positive trends and to
build on this foundation in order to
ensure on the ground
coexistence
cooperation between the two communities
the azerbaijani community and the
armenian community this is currently the
main objective our main focus and i
would not go further
in these plans i thank you very much
thank you very much our press conference
is now over
you